أهلاً بكم مجدداً في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي. هذه الحلقة السادسة. اليوم سنركز على أحد تطبيقاتي المفضلة
للحواسيب الكمومية وهو محاكاة الطبيعة. في هذه الحلقة سنناقش الخطوات المطلوبة
للقيام بذلك لأي نوع من مشاكل الديناميكا الكمومية وهي مشكلة إيجاد كيف يتغير وصف
نظام كمومي مع الزمن. سنفعل هذا على مستوى عالٍ أولاً ثم ننظر في مثال محدد ونستعرضه
بالتفصيل وتحديداً تجربة IBM لعام 2023 التي أظهرت الفائدة الكمومية. لبعض الحافز السريع في
البداية، إحدى أشهر القصص التي نرويها مراراً وتكراراً في مجال الحوسبة الكمومية
قصة Richard Feynman وهو يلقي محاضرة في Caltech عام 1959 ويقدم في الأساس
حافزاً للمجال بأكمله لعقود قادمة. كان عنوان الخطاب "هناك متسع كبير في القاع"
عنوان طريف لكن الفكرة الأساسية كانت أنه يدعي أنه لا يزال هناك الكثير من الفيزياء الغنية لاكتشافها
على المستوى المجهري.
تلك المحاضرة تحديداً لم تحظَ باهتمام كبير حتى الثمانينيات عندما تطورت التقنية بشكل ملحوظ. وFeynman
أيضاً وضّح ونقّح رسالته مع الوقت. عاد إلى Caltech في الثمانينيات وقدم ورقة أخرى بعنوان
"محاكاة الطبيعة بالحواسيب" حيث قال تحديداً إنه يريد التحدث عن إمكانية
وجود محاكاة دقيقة بحيث يفعل الحاسوب بالضبط نفس ما تفعله الطبيعة.
أي القدرة على التخلص من التقريبات الخام لما يحدث على المستوى الذري واستبدالها
بحواسيب تفهم وتسخر فيزياء الكم ليس فقط لمحاكاة ما تفعله الطبيعة بل لمضاهاتها.
الآن تذكروا هذا الرسم البياني الزمني الذي عرضته في حلقة سابقة. في طرف كانت مشاكل سهلة
الحل ولن تحتاج لأي تسريع يمكن أن يقدمه الكم. لكن في الطرف الآخر لدينا مشاكل
صعبة جداً وتحتاج آلات كمومية متسامحة مع الأخطاء لا نملكها بعد.
لحسن الحظ نعتقد أن هناك عدداً لا بأس به من مشاكل المحاكاة التي تقع هنا في المنتصف وهي المنطقة التي
يمكننا العمل فيها حالياً. وهناك أسباب كثيرة للحماس والاهتمام بهذا الاحتمال لأن
محاكاة الطبيعة هي الأساس لكثير من مجالات التطبيق المثيرة. على سبيل المثال لا الحصر إذا تمكنا من محاكاة
الطبيعة بشكل أفضل يمكننا تسريع اكتشاف مواد جديدة وإنشاء أدوية وعلاجات أفضل أو
حتى استكشاف فيزياء جديدة تكمن وراء فيزياء الجسيمات أو علم الكونيات. لكن قبل أن تتمكنوا أنتم أو أي شخص من محاولة
تطبيق الحوسبة الكمومية على هذه المجالات المثيرة حالياً ستحتاجون لفهم الخطوات الأساسية في
سير عمل نموذجي قائم على المحاكاة.
أولاً ستريدون تحديد نظام كمومي محل اهتمام. هذا سيُعلمكم عن الهاملتوني الذي يحكم تطوره
الزمني ووصف ذي معنى لخصائصه الابتدائية أو حالته.
ثم ستحتاجون لإيجاد طريقة مناسبة لتنفيذ التطور الزمني لهذه الحالة. مع ترتيب هذه المكونات
الخطوات التالية تتضمن تنفيذ التجربة الفعلية.
هذه تشمل عموماً تحسين تنفيذ الـ circuit الكمومية لخوارزمية التطور الزمني وتنفيذ
الـ circuit أو الدوائر على العتاد الكمومي والمعالجة اللاحقة للنتائج. لذا يمكننا
تسمية الخطوات الأساسية في تجربة محاكاة كالتالي:
تحديد هاملتوني النظام، ترميز الهاملتوني، تحضير الحالة، تطور الحالة،
تحسين الـ circuit، تنفيذ الـ circuit، والمعالجة اللاحقة.
لكن هذه خطوات مفصلة جداً. تذكروا أن المراحل الأربع لإطار عمل أنماط Qiskit الذي يساعدنا
في فهم كيفية تنفيذ روتين في Qiskit هي: التعيين، تحسين الـ circuit، تنفيذ الـ circuit،
والمعالجة اللاحقة. لذا هذه الخطوات الأربع الأولى هنا مشمولة فعلاً تحت مظلة التعيين وهذا
هو سبب قضائنا حلقة كاملة على هذه المرحلة الأولى وإذا فاتتكم يرجى العودة ومشاهدة الحلقة السابقة.
الآن لنستعرض أولاً ماذا تعني هذه الخطوات قبل الغوص في أي كود. أول شيء أساسي نحتاج
فعله لإجراء تجربة محاكاة هو تحديد الهاملتوني الذي يصف النظام. أحياناً وغالباً
تكون هذه معروفة جيداً وأحياناً أخرى علينا تجميعها من فهم مساهمات الطاقة
للمجموعات الفرعية الصغيرة من النظام الكامل هكذا حيث hi هو الهاملتوني المؤثر على أحد الأنظمة الفرعية n من h.
سنحتاج أيضاً لملاحظة ما إذا كان النظام يتكون من فرميونات أو بوزونات إذا كنا نتعامل مع جسيمات أولية. التالي
نحتاج لترميز الهاملتوني وترجمته إلى مصطلحات يمكن للحواسيب الكمومية فهمها. في كثير من الأحيان
ستتكون هذه الهاملتونيات من جسيمات أولية أو أنظمة لف. إذا كنا نحاكي فرميونات أو بوزونات
سنحتاج لاختيار تحويل ترميز مثل Jordan-Wigner أو Bravyi-Kitaev. هذه التحويلات
ستخبرنا كيف نترجم تعريف الهاملتوني المكتوب بدلالة المكونات الأصلية أي الفرميونات أو
البوزونات إلى مشغلات Pauli التي تتحول بسهولة إلى بوابات على حاسوب كمومي. مثلاً تحويل Jordan-Wigner
المعرف هنا يعطي تعييناً من مشغلات الفرميون إلى مشغلات Pauli. إذا كنا نتعامل أصلاً
مع أنظمة لف 1/2 وهي شائعة جداً فنحن جاهزون باستثناء أي معاملات تطبيع محتملة
ولا نحتاج لاستخدام مخطط ترميز. بعد ترميز الهاملتوني المطلوب في مجموعة
بوابات الحاسوب الكمومي الخطوة الحاسمة التالية هي تحديد الحالة الكمومية الابتدائية المناسبة التي نبدأ منها
محاكاتنا. يجب أن تعكس هذه الحالة مثالياً بعض المعنى الفيزيائي أو التكوين
للنظام قيد الدراسة. مثلاً إذا كنا مهتمين باستكشاف طاقة الحالة الأرضية لجزيء قد
نبدأ بتقريب Hartree-Fock أو أنساتز آخر سهل التحضير له تداخل كبير مع الحالة
الأرضية الحقيقية. اختيار الحالة الأرضية الابتدائية يؤثر ليس فقط على تقارب الخوارزميات التباينية
مثل VQE محلل القيم الذاتية الكمومي التباينيي بل أيضاً على دقة وكفاءة
التطور الزمني أو أخذ العينات في تقدير الطور الكمومي. في الأساس الحالة الابتدائية تعمل
كنقطة انطلاق للحساب وتمهد الطريق لاستخلاص مرصودات مفيدة عن النظام الكمومي
الذي ننمذجه. تحضير حالة عشوائية من n qubit حيث ci هي حالات الأساس الحسابي و ai هو
معامل كل حالة وشرط التطبيع 2 أس n ناقص واحد يمكن مقاربته عموماً عن طريق
تهيئة الحالة بالمشغل O. حالة البداية ستكون حالة الأساس المعيارية كلها أصفار وتُكتب غالباً
هكذا للتبسيط. بشكل عام هذا يتطلب عدداً أسياً من بوابات CNOT. في كثير من الأحيان نكون
مهتمين بحالة ابتدائية محددة للنظام ويمكن تنفيذ تحضيرها بكمية معقولة
من الموارد. حالات الجداء مثلاً التي لا تكون فيها الـ qubit متشابكة مع بعضها تحتاج فقط عمليات
على qubit مفرد. الآن لم تتح لنا الفرصة فعلاً للحديث عن التقسيم بطريقة Trotter
بعد رغم أن بعضكم ربما على دراية به بالفعل. في الأساس تقسيم Trotter هو طريقة لحساب الأُس المصفوفي
تستخدم تقريبات للتعامل مع الطبيعة الأسية للمشغلات غير المتبادلة. عندما لا يتبادل مشغلان مثل HA
و HB فعلينا استخدام حيلة ذكية وتطبيق الأُسيات المقابلة
لـ e أس سالب i HA و e أس سالب i HB لعدد n من
المرات. تُطبق مشغلات التطور المتناوبة. لن أستعرض الإثبات هنا لكنني سأشارك رابطاً
لإثبات بسيط جميل لهذه العبارة في الوصف. لكن الرسالة الأساسية هي هذه: التطور الزمني هو
جزء مهم من التعيين أيضاً. تقسيم Trotter يكسر التفاعل المستمر إلى خطوات منفصلة يمكن
تنفيذها على حاسوب كمومي. بعد توليد الـ circuit المقسمة بطريقة Trotter نكون أنهينا أخيراً
خطوة التعيين. يمكننا الآن الانتقال إلى تحسين الـ circuit.
للقيام بذلك هذا ما يجب إنجازه: يجب أن يكون هناك تخطيط للـ qubit يُعيّن الـ qubit الافتراضية في
الـ circuit على qubit فيزيائية على العتاد. هذا مطلوب لأن العتاد يمكن أن يكون له طوبولوجيات معينة
تُقيد التفاعل المباشر للـ qubit الفيزيائية. بينما تنفيذ
circuit كمومية غالباً يفترض قدرة أي qubit على التفاعل مع أي qubit أخرى. ثم نحتاج لإدراج
بوابات التبديل حسب الحاجة لتوجيه التفاعلات بين الـ qubit غير المتصلة. نحتاج لترجمة
البوابات في الـ circuit إلى تعليمات معمارية مجموعة التعليمات أو تعليمات ISA التي
يمكن تنفيذها مباشرة على العتاد. ثم نحتاج لإجراء تحسينات على الـ circuit لتقليل
عمق الـ circuit وعدد البوابات. يمكن تنفيذ هذه الخطوة أيضاً على الـ circuit الافتراضية حيث لم تُعيّن الـ qubit
بعد على طوبولوجيا الجهاز. لكن تذكروا أن الكثير من هذا يتم تلقائياً لكم في
Qiskit. سنرى بالضبط كيف في القسم التالي من هذا الدرس. بعد خطوة التحسين نكون مستعدين لتشغيل
الـ circuit باستخدام Primitive. لمعظم تجارب المحاكاة تكونون مهتمين بفهم تغير
خصائص معينة للنظام مع الزمن. لذا على الأرجح ستستخدمون Primitive المقدر لأنه
سيتيح لكم قياس القيم المتوقعة للمرصودات المقابلة لخصائص محددة. ثم
سنُهيئ أفضل الخيارات للمقدر والتي يمكن أن تضيف تقنيات قمع وتخفيف الأخطاء. أخيراً سنشغل
التجربة. الخطوة الأخيرة هي المعالجة اللاحقة لكل البيانات. هذه تستخلص القيم المتوقعة المقاسة أو إذا
كنتم تستخدمون أخذ العينات فتوزيع الاحتمالات في الأساس الحسابي. إذا كان كل ما تحتاجونه
هو القيم المتوقعة للمرصودات المهمة فيمكن الحصول عليها مباشرة من Primitive
المقدر سواء بقيمها الخام أو المخففة من الأخطاء. في كثير من الأحيان سيُستخدم بعد ذلك القيم المتوقعة المقاسة
لحسابات أخرى لكميات أخرى مهمة لا تتطلب حوسبة كمومية ويمكن
حسابها على حاسوب كلاسيكي.
الآن سنستعرض مثالاً حقيقياً من ورقة مؤثرة جداً نشرتها IBM قبل بضع سنوات بعنوان
"دليل على فائدة الحوسبة الكمومية قبل التسامح مع الأخطاء". هذه الورقة التي نختصرها بمودة
بورقة الفائدة أصبحت ورقة مؤثرة جداً في مجال الحوسبة الكمومية فور نشرها تقريباً.
الأطروحة العامة للورقة هي أن حاسوباً كمومياً مشوشاً أنتج نتائج دقيقة أو قيماً متوقعة
باستخدام 127 qubit و 2,880 بوابة خارج قدرات حوسبة
القوة الغاشمة وهي المحاكاة الدقيقة للدوائر الكمومية المنفذة بواسطة العتاد. هذا العمل كان
مهماً أيضاً لأنه أظهر أن حاسوباً كمومياً يمكن استخدامه للتحقق من أو مقارنة النتائج مع طرق
كلاسيكية تقريبية أخرى لمحاكاة كمومية مثل خوارزميات شبكة الموتر حيث الحل
لم يكن معروفاً مسبقاً. ما هو رائع أيضاً هو أن الآخرين يمكنهم الآن باستخدام أنظمة IBM الكمومية على
السحابة و Qiskit تكرار والتحقق من هذه النتائج بأنفسهم.
سأستعرض لكم كيفية فعل ذلك بالضبط. لهذا المثال سنكون أكثر تحديداً بعض الشيء حول
الخطوات المتضمنة في تعيين هذه المشكلة إلى مدخلات يمكن لجهاز كمومي فهمها. في هذه الحالة سنحاكي
ديناميكا المغنطة الكلية لنظام من ثنائيات أقطاب مغناطيسية لفية على شبكة في
وجود حقل مغناطيسي خارجي. يمكن وصف النظام بنموذج Ising مع حقل مغناطيسي عرضي.
ننمذج هذا بـ circuit كمومية ذات معاملات حيث تتوافق المعاملات مع القيمة القابلة للضبط لتفاعل
اللف-اللف أو تفاعل Z وقوة الحقل المغناطيسي X. الآن
هذه السلسلة تُسمى الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي. لذا سنناقش أيضاً إجراءات في هذه التجربة
سننفذها لجعل النتائج أفضل ما يمكن. التالي سنناقش كيفية إزالة
الـ qubit السيئة أو الـ qubit ذات دقة البوابة المنخفضة أو أوقات فك الترابط التي يمكن أن تؤثر جذرياً على
النتائج التجريبية. يمكن أن تحدث هذه الـ qubit السيئة بسبب معايرة سابقة سيئة
أو أنظمة ثنائية المستوى تتفاعل مع الـ qubit. إزالة بعض الـ qubit من طوبولوجيا العتاد الأصلية يتوافق مع
اعتبار نظام على شبكة موصوفة بالطوبولوجيا الناتجة. سنناقش أيضاً إنشاء
الـ circuit الكمومية ذات المعاملات التي تنفذ التطور الزمني للنظام عبر تقسيم Trotter.
لهذا الغرض سيكون من المهم تحديد طبقات التشابك وهي جزء حرج لتقنية تخفيف
الأخطاء الرئيسية التي سنستخدمها لاحقاً. في هذه المرحلة أريد التأكد من أنكم أيها الجمهور تعلمون
أنه يمكنكم المتابعة مع كل ما سأناقشه في الدفتر التعليمي المرفق أدناه وعلى موقع IBM
منصة التعلم الكمومي. في هذا الدفتر التعليمي ما قد تلاحظونه هو أننا أنشأنا سلسلة من الدوال
المساعدة في بداية الدفتر يمكننا استدعاؤها لاحقاً لتسهيل حياتنا قليلاً. أريد ذكرها
الآن ليس لأنها جزء من العملية الرسمية أو الشكلية ولكن لأن هذا ما يفعله التجريبيون غالباً
في الحياة الواقعية لمساعدتهم في تشغيل هذه الأنواع من التجارب. وتُرينا أيضاً كيف سنفكك
مشكلتنا أكثر. الدوال التي نعرفها في الدفتر هي كالتالي: إزالة اقترانات الـ qubit.
تعريف اقترانات الـ qubit. بناء اقترانات الطبقات. بناء طبقات التشابك. وأخيراً تعريف
الـ circuit المقسمة بطريقة Trotter. بعد ذلك لنتحدث عن اقترانات الطبقات التي تساعد في تعريف كيفية
تفاعل الـ qubit مع جيرانها أثناء المحاكاة. أجهزتنا الكمومية تستخدم شيئاً يُسمى التخطيط
السداسي الثقيل وهو نمط خاص لربط الـ qubit. في هذا التخطيط يمكننا تجميع الاتصالات المسماة حواف في ثلاث
مجموعات منفصلة حيث لا يتشارك اتصالان في نفس المجموعة qubit واحد. هذا
مهم لأنه على حاسوب كمومي حقيقي لا يمكننا تشغيل بوابات ثنائية الـ qubit في نفس الوقت إذا كانت تتضمن
نفس الـ qubit. كل qubit يمكنه المشاركة في بوابة واحدة فقط في المرة الواحدة. بتقسيم
جميع الاتصالات إلى ثلاث طبقات يمكننا تطبيق بوابات ثنائية الـ qubit عبر الجهاز بأكمله في ثلاث
جولات مع التأكد من عدم استخدام أي qubit في أكثر من بوابة واحدة لكل طبقة. هذه
البوابات تنفذ تفاعل ZZ من نموذج Ising وتتكرر في كل خطوة من المحاكاة تُسمى
خطوة Trotter. اللف يُعدّل الضوضاء في الجهاز بحيث حتى نموذج ضوضاء بسيط
من المرجح أن يكون دقيقاً. هذا يجعل من الممكن أيضاً تعلم نموذج الضوضاء بدقة واستخدام المعلومات
المحصلة في تقنيات تخفيف الأخطاء.
بعد ذلك علينا إزالة الـ qubit السيئة من قائمتنا المحتملة للـ qubit الفيزيائية التي يمكننا استخدامها في
التجربة. كما قلت يمكن أن تصبح الـ qubit سيئة لأسباب متنوعة مختلفة. أحياناً مجرد معايرة
سيئة وهو خطأ بسيط يمكن حله بإعادة المعايرة.
أحياناً يكون أكثر تعقيداً ومرتبطاً بما نسميه TLS وهو عيب سطحي ثنائي المستوى
يؤدي إلى تقلبات في معاملات الـ qubit والاسترخاء. يمكن
حل هذا بتسخين النظام بأكمله قليلاً ثم تبريده. لكن هذا يستغرق وقتاً وليس ممكناً
عبر السحابة. لذا حالياً الأسهل هو استبعادها من قائمة الـ qubit الفيزيائية
المحتملة التي سنستخدمها. يمكنكم تحديد أي qubit لا تتصرف كما هو متوقع بسهولة من منصة IBM الكمومية.
يمكنكم رسم خصائص الـ qubit هناك في المنصة أو تنزيلها كملف CSV. ثم أنشئوا قائمة بجميع
الـ qubit التي تريدون استبعادها وببساطة أزيلوها من قائمة الـ qubit الفيزيائية الكلية على الجهاز.
حسناً. الآن لنتابع مع خطوة التعيين لتوليد الـ circuit المقسمة بطريقة Trotter. كما أظهرنا
سابقاً تقسيم Trotter يحول التطور الزمني إلى سلسلة من الخطوات وعلينا تحديد عدد الخطوات.
سنختار ستة هنا. لكن بشكل عام الاستراتيجية هي الموازنة بين ما يُسمى خطأ Trotter وهو
خطأ تقريب خوارزمي مع الخطأ الناتج عن فك الترابط. المزيد من خطوات Trotter يقلل خطأ التقريب
لكنه يتطلب دوائر كمومية أعمق تتعرض لمزيد من ضوضاء فك الترابط. سنعرف
الـ circuit بدلالة معامل theta وهو قوة الحقل المغناطيسي الخارجي واقترانات الطبقات و
عدد الخطوات والـ qubit وبالطبع الـ backend للجهاز. بسبب
اعتماد مغنطة النظام على قوة الحقل المغناطيسي الخارجي من المثير
تنفيذ المحاكاة عند قيم مختلفة لقوة الحقل المغناطيسي والتي تترجم إلى زوايا مختلفة لدوران RX
في الـ circuit. الآن بعد توليد الـ circuit سننتقل إلى تحسينها.
الخطوة الأولى هنا هي تعريف مدير التمريرات. تذكروا في سياق SDK الخاص بـ Qiskit يشير النقل إلى
عملية تحويل circuit مدخلة إلى شكل مناسب للتنفيذ على جهاز كمومي.
النقل يحدث عادةً في تسلسل من الخطوات تُسمى تمريرات الـ transpiler. مدير التمريرات هو كائن
يخزن قائمة بتمريرات الـ transpiler ويمكنه تنفيذها على circuit. أنشئوا مدير تمريرات بتهيئة كائن
مدير التمريرات مع قائمة بتمريرات الـ transpiler. في النهاية سينشئ مدير التمريرات
circuit ISA وهي circuit يجب كتابتها بدلالة معمارية مجموعة تعليمات الـ backend
التي تصف الـ circuit والبوابات الأصلية للـ backend لكنها تفتقر لمعلومات التوقيت المطلوبة لتشغيل
الـ circuit. الآن نحن مستعدون لتنفيذ الـ circuit وهي الخطوة الثالثة من أنماط Qiskit. كما ذُكر سابقاً
سنستخدم بالتأكيد المقدر هنا كـ Primitive المختار لهذه التجربة بما أننا نريد قياس
المغنطة الكلية للنظام وتقدير القيمة المتوقعة للمرصودات هو ما صُمم المقدر
من أجله. في هذه الخطوة سيكون من الحاسم أيضاً تحديد خياراتنا لتخفيف الأخطاء. سنستخدم استقراء الضوضاء
الصفرية للحصول على أفضل نتائج ممكنة. تحديداً في الدفتر التعليمي سترون أننا نحدد قيمتين أو أكثر
لعامل الضوضاء لتقييم النماذج المستقرأة ونحدد
تضخيم الأخطاء الاحتمالي كخيار التضخيم. الآن تضخيم
الأخطاء الاحتمالي أو PEA كان حقاً تقنية تخفيف الأخطاء المفضلة هنا لأنها تتوسع بشكل أفضل
بكثير من الخيارات الأخرى. وهذا ما يهم عندما نعمل على مستوى أكثر من 100 qubit.
أخيراً وليس آخراً شغلوا التجربة وستستغرق بعض الوقت لتكتمل لكن حالياً لنرجع إلى البيانات
المخزنة من الدفتر التعليمي. سنفحص البيانات الوصفية مع ملاحظة خاصة للبوابات الطبقية
والطبقات المخففة بما أننا على وشك استخدامها لإزالة مجموعة من الأخطاء من بياناتنا الخام. نحن شبه مستعدين
لرسم نتائجنا النهائية. لكن قبل ذلك لنضف استراحة سريعة هنا حول ما يُقصد بالضبط باستقراء الضوضاء
الصفرية أو ZNE. غطيناه بإيجاز في حلقات سابقة لكن للمراجعة استقراء الضوضاء الصفرية
هو تقنية لتخفيف الأخطاء تزيل تأثيرات ضوضاء غير معروفة أثناء تنفيذ الـ circuit يمكن
توسيعها بطريقة معروفة. تفترض أن القيم المتوقعة تتوسع مع الضوضاء بدالة معروفة موضحة هنا حيث
معاملات lambda تحدد قوة الضوضاء ويمكن تضخيمها. يمكننا تنفيذ ZNE بالخطوات التالية.
أولاً تضخيم ضوضاء الـ circuit لعدة عوامل ضوضاء. lambda 1 و lambda 2
و lambda 3 وهكذا. تشغيل كل circuit مُضخمة الضوضاء لقياس
القيمة المتوقعة a عند lambda 1 و a عند lambda 2 وهكذا. ثم الاستقراء إلى حد الضوضاء
الصفرية وهو القيمة المتوقعة a عند صفر.
التحدي الرئيسي في تنفيذ ZNE بنجاح هو امتلاك نموذج دقيق للضوضاء في القيمة المتوقعة
وتضخيم الضوضاء بطريقة معروفة.
هناك ثلاث طرق شائعة لتنفيذ تضخيم الأخطاء في ZNE: توسيع مدة النبضة عبر المعايرة
وتكرار البوابات في دورات الهوية وإضافة ضوضاء عبر أخذ عينات من قنوات Pauli.
نسمي الأخيرة PEA. تضخيم الأخطاء الاحتمالي هو الخيار الأفضل هنا لأن توسيع النبضات مكلف
حسابياً جداً. طي البوابات يفتقر لضمانات نظرية في الحفاظ على انحياز الضوضاء. لكن PEA يمكن
تطبيقه على أي circuit يمكن تشغيلها بعوامل ضوضاء أصلية لكنه يتطلب تعلم نموذج الضوضاء. PEA يفترض
نفس نموذج الضوضاء القائم على الطبقات مثل إلغاء الأخطاء الاحتمالي.
لكنه يتجنب الحمل الإضافي لأخذ العينات الذي يتوسع أسياً مع ضوضاء الـ circuit. لتعلم نموذج الضوضاء
علينا أولاً تحديد الطبقات الفريدة لعمليات الـ qubit الثنائية في الـ circuit.
لكل طبقة نقوم بلف Pauli للبوابات الثنائية الـ qubit لضمان وصف الضوضاء جيداً بنموذج ضوضاء التخميد.
نكرر أزواج هوية من الطبقات بأعماق متفاوتة وأخيراً نُلائم دقة أو خطأ لكل قناة ضوضاء.
وبالطبع بينما أنصح بفهم هذه الطريقة إلى حد ما فإن تنفيذها يدوياً في Qiskit
أبسط بكثير كما هو موضح في الدفتر التعليمي. الآن أخيراً لنلقِ نظرة على البيانات المرسومة. الخط
الرمادي المنقط يُظهر النتائج الدقيقة المحصلة بطرق كلاسيكية تقريبية مع تقارب خطأ التقريب
إلى عتبة منخفضة. كما ترون البيانات الخام لعوامل الضوضاء المختلفة التي اخترناها في
البداية بعيدة بشكل ملحوظ عن هذا الخط المنقط. الخط الأزرق المتصل يُظهر البيانات مع أخذ معالجة ZNE
في الاعتبار. ويمكنكم ملاحظة فوراً أنها أقرب بكثير من النتائج الدقيقة.
باختصار القيم المشوشة تُظهر انحرافاً عالياً عن القيم الدقيقة.
القيم المخففة قريبة من القيم الدقيقة مما يُظهر فائدة تقنية التخفيف القائمة على PEA.
وهذا يختتم هذه الحلقة في الأساس. لتلخيص سريع لما تعلمناه: المحاكاة الكمومية هي أحد
أكثر مجالات التطبيق الواعدة على المدى القصير إلى المتوسط.
لها تطبيقات واسعة النطاق من الأدوية إلى فيزياء الطاقات العالية
وعلوم المواد والمزيد. ورقة الفائدة من IBM المنشورة في 2023 أشارت
إلى الطريق نحو القدرة على استخدام الحواسيب الكمومية للاكتشاف العلمي. وقد عملنا من خلال
الدفتر التعليمي المرافق لتلك الورقة بتعمق. خطوات العمل على مشكلة محاكاة من البداية
إلى النهاية مباشرة نسبياً خاصة بمجرد إتقانها. وأملي أنكم
يمكنكم من الآن فصاعداً استخدام هذا الفيديو والدفتر التعليمي كدليل لمزيد من مشاكل المحاكاة في المستقبل.
شكراً على المشاهدة وسنراكم في المرة القادمة في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي.